étrange balade à la réunion texte de
christelle minier photographie perdant
chez moka édition il ya d'abord eu ses
trois pingouins qui bronzer sur le sable
puis ce panda qui voulait jouer à cache
cache avec moi dans les cales j'ai
trouvé ça bizarre
à travers les herbes de la savane une
créera rue a surgi et m'a fait sursauter
j'ai couru vite pour me cacher au bord
de la rivière deux gros yeux observer
sans un bruit
j'ai filé dans la forêt on entend des
glisser allons sur les branches j'ai
traversé la plage sur le dos d'un zèbre
sauvage nous allons volonté galoper
quand une girafe m'a soudain demandé on
et vous baigner
quelle étrange balade a dit l'éléphant
étonnez
vous avez dit étrange un rhinocéros
arlette m'a doublé sur la piste jean
perdait les pédales c'est alors que des
pas ont fait trembler la plaine 1
raisonner et là je me suis réveillé